[Music]
some of the stuff as i was
thumbing through it and of course you
know i'm going to gravitate to the money
chapter money is not the root of all
evil
and you guys are not against uh wealth
building
yeah um and um the fun one in there is
you get the same you get everybody
in our world gets a line that that
everybody thinks is original
and they come up to you and they always
come up to me and make some lame joke
about a credit card right
and they come up to you guys and go i
was a minimalist once i grew up poor
yeah you know and you guys hear that
like every third person in a book line
right
right yeah and so minimalism is not
poverty and it's not an advocate you're
not advocating
poverty and you're not calling nice
things even
um evil no not at all i mean
minimalism sounds like a really radical
lifestyle but
you know the way we look at it is it's
really just a practical lifestyle
because
let's say everyone stops spending money
right now the economy would crash right
and then if we go to the other side of
it and we spend way too much as
as we saw in 2008 the economy crashes
so really i think minimalism is that
middle ground approach to
spending money to bringing things into
your life and it's not just
you know physical possessions yes we
talk about that but really relationships
jobs there's so many things that we
don't really
sit and ask why we bring these things
into our lives and i think that's what
minimalism really helps people do is get
to the root
of why how might your life be better
with less how might your life be better
with that job how might your life be
better with
that that person in your life and uh
yeah that's so minimalism really gets to
the y
i think that's a good way to say it i'm
personally experiencing
a different version of your material
than i ever have before
right this second um and i'm starting to
kind of have the theory and you probably
have already espoused this theory but
i'm just
observing it in myself that that um
things can start out serving a purpose
and after a season they need to go
absolutely like we just
we've got this big fabulous house that
sharon and i built
uh 12 years ago and it's it's amazing
i mean and we've had charity events up
there
that have raised more money for
ministries and for charity than the
house costs so it's been a good return
on investment for god okay he made money
on it
and so and we've got to live there too
that was pretty cool you know
so but it's it's run its course yes and
so we sold we sold it the other day
oh wow and so we're going to be moving
in a couple months which has led to
cleaning out the closets right yeah
and you go in there and you go why do i
have all this crap and it's kind of
but these things when they started 12
years ago including the house itself
yeah had a purpose but they've lived
they've outlived their season
yeah and they need to go yeah it's so
important you say that because
minimalism is not this destination
i wish we could like sit here and write
out like well you're moving to a new
place dave well let's write out the
hundred things that you need and the
hundred things that your wife needs and
and since you'll be you know living in
wherever here's another list of 50
things it just doesn't work that way
minimalism is a way to kind of help you
call it's really
to help you just get clear on what adds
value today what adds value tomorrow
because yeah it is so important to
recognize
the things in my life today may not add
value tomorrow and vice versa and that's
okay
yeah my daughter is eight she doesn't
still play with the same toy she did
when she was three right
yeah the average kid actually has 300
toys they play with about 12 daily
of course we as adults were the same
thing we have our own toys right now we
they they sort of we pretend they're
important things but
the truth is that a lot of those things
they did add value for a season but they
stopped adding value and so
minimalism is also that process where we
constantly question we keep asking
ourselves
does this serve a purpose does this add
value to my life
and if not we've got some rules in there
that will help you sort of let go
of the excess stuff because letting go
is not something that you do
letting go is something you stop doing
you stop clinging
to the excess stuff you stop claiming to
the past or to toxic relationships
or to the way you wish things would be
dr don john colony talks about that all
the time grieve the past and move on
you know this thing you had this thing
painted in your mind the way it was
supposed to be and it's not that way
yeah and so let's just grieve that and
take a step on that's right you know
let's just move on and and
and deal with that so very very cool so
hoarding
is like the extreme opposite because it
that's a
that is not a it's a physical
manifestation
of of a psychological problem yeah that
is really the
it's the ultimate out of control
consumer
materialist yeah let's talk about
hoarding there's five stages of hoarding
we write about it a bit in the book
and the truth is we're all hoarders to
some extent oh yeah i
i figured it out cleaning out my dadgum
colossal for the last three weeks i'm
like
why have i i've not even seen this in
three years
why is it here the minimalists are going
to kill me
in the book we we took 40 47 different
families they did ryan's packing party
experiment
where they box up everything in their
house they pretend like they're moving
because as you just
illuminated here as soon as we move it's
the one time in our lives we're forced
to deal with all of those indiscretions
all of those things that we purchase the
things that we thought were going to
make us happy we don't even remember
so those objects of our desire they soon
over
a couple years they become the objects
of our discontent
and so when that happens it's it's just
time to let go
so this is a great time for you to be
decluttering yeah yeah well i'm so
freaking organized in ocd about
everything else
because i don't have clutter clutter but
then when you dig
behind the layer you find it back there
and i'm going it's
disgusting yeah organizing doesn't work
organizing is one of the problems it's
the reason
i have a big problem with like the
container store and these other places
they sell
us things to help us hide our clutter
we have well-organized clutter exactly
and so organizing is often just
well-planned hoarding i was the same way
i was a well-organized hoarder so i had
those 300 000 items
and they were neatly stored in an
ordinal system of bins and boxes and
alphabetized
i bet it was completely i bet it was
just as ocd as i am i thought it was the
same one
oh yeah i remember taking trips with him
to walmart to get the bins and
yeah yeah yeah and they all got labels
oh he's a little machine
label machine yeah yeah he's that guy
yeah i love that
now i would have to hire somebody no i
don't know this is great
love people use things
so this is got an element to it of just
being
intentional to keep things in their
place
and they're a sub category way below
relationships which are really all that
matters
yeah that is the truth and that's the
way you guys have laid this out yeah
yeah i mean the the stuff is just the
initial bite at the apple
it leads to so much more because now we
have to decide what we do with our time
what we do with our attention what we do
with our money i mean money we look at
it as being the most important resource
and it is an important resource
but it's really our time and attention
that and the only thing that's good for
us what it does
yeah that's all it's good for yeah very
good stuff
thanks for coming by guys hey thanks for
having us love these guys the minimalist
dot com slash tour for the 20 city tour
don't miss it
pick up the new book you will love it
called love people use things because
the opposite
never works this is the ramsay show